if you think about it the most basic
thing of human communication is is I
conduct by the device seeing you you get
a whole nother world of interaction the
window to the soul
window exactly the window to the soul or
the window to the brain look around look
to the right look to the left you see
Kempinski is the co-founder and CEO of
youmove based here in jerusalem the
company has developed a way to replace
eye tracking gear that usually cost tens
of thousands of dollars with algorithms
that can run on an iPad or smartphone
it's a little disorienting at first to
try and play a video game just by moving
your head so you see head movement I
movement
iris movement blinks and then and then
analysis of that Kempinski hopes the
technology will give us new rapid
insights into conditions like
concussions so this is like when they
share in the white light that you have
to follow I mean using doctors doing
that exactly and then based on the score
we can tell if I have a concussion I
hate old you don't have a don't have a
concussion Kempinski thinks that these
hard science applications with
real-world uses distinguish israel's
tech scene especially for jerusalem star
nuts people are looking for you know
real deep tech can't say I'm you know
making an A for taking pictures of food
you have to give a you know a real
explanation to your Jewish grandmother
about what what is that for